a messy divorce news already like this
one submitted by death boot man request
a trial by combat losing Swartz to
resolve a dispute with his ex-wife wants
to fight his ex-wife with sword [ __ ]
that is the ex-wife Ronda Rousey or
something what are they calling game of
Thrones
I would like it's [ __ ] up if like
she's a Highlander though but at least
it's swords you ever any mortal only can
be one
yeah psycho that was a sick movie dude
an assault it was a so easy it was the
show The WB boomers it's just the guy
with the big ass or and they fight
people like 95 this is the first time
you ever tell me about like TV or movie
or anything that's true
it wasn't a Boomer show Geo it was not a
Boomer show I'm 84 what are you talking
about what this thing was a joke was it
a good joke right yeah okay so this guy
named David he has been destroyed
legally by his ex-wife and her attorney
so knows money got taken away he's
requesting that a so he's asking an Iowa
court to agree to a trial by combat and
so he explained that he hopes to meet
his ex-wife and her lawyer on the field
of battle where he will rend their souls
from their Corporal body
I totally see why his wife divorced he
withdraws it trophy room
calling because um yeah so what he's
saying is that from the Corporal bodies
come on dude that's like awesome that's
some Diablo to [ __ ] he noted that trial
by combat has never been explicitly
banned or restricted as a rights in the
United States
and so he also added that it had been
used as recently as 1818 in British
Court
that's precedent and so to prepare he's
requesting twelve weeks lead time to
have one katana and one what katashi
well cuz I just for for or forged for
use that's what he's at requesting I'd
go to hand clear more you know every
time pretty slow though very slow but
would love the powerful speak to hand
Claymore it's a big-ass [ __ ] saying
[ __ ] sore well yeah you are [ __ ]
I got from Highlander because they have
they had no to hand claim where I would
want to swore that the guy had off a
final fantasy oh the [ __ ] you got clouds
disappointment into here man a multi
doesn't mean I just got a lot of sighs
give it to here sighs now I've only been
seeing the geek side though well you see
some of the real one no and be like few
episodes nothing what you just said
right now is a [ __ ] geek like geek
deep chasm it's a it's a geek chasm no
but he was good he was good
pillbot of it please send on a Boomer I
can always get out okay so anyway back
to this so then that's when David he
said that he filed the motion out of
frustration with the legal system where
he and his ex are litigating property
tax and custody disputes and he also
took issue with his exes attorney he
says I think I've met mr. Hudson's
absurdity with my own absurdity love it
I love it that's my favorite technique
in that's really cool I uh you know but
you know the number she had to do for
that one you opened I mean did we all
walked in your [ __ ] geek closet and
we just found a giant [ __ ] black hole
into the into the void yeah with that
comment a lot of [ __ ] going on over here
man you got it as a comment you know
this you have to be open to a lot of
different things so you know I indulge
and a couple of things we'll play
okay I wear my badge is proudly okay
[ __ ] role-playing games are you playing
what you play uh start with Zelda
obviously didn't link you know me and
then link equals athletic is so I think
is it was yeah but it was Zelda first
and then it was like the return to them
yeah I'm talking about like I'm come on
the Greg Lynn the Tendo first before I
get to know did you just let Sadat that
you out of yourself as not a zealous lap
people for like no I thought that you
were I thought you were lying to me for
a second no no I was sniffing the winds
because you're no liar and I was just
trying to that's why it's like you
doubted you to you okay metroid is a man
too don't you
Oh I mean there are there's a lot of
controversy it's Mitchell is no no it's
controversy metroid is actually amazing
sadness right seven seven seven sizzle
wonder Metroid let's go pal you wanna go
I'll go all then go all [ __ ] day
buddy okay who's the best art Star Trek
captain in my opinion or a popular
opinion and your opinion a car yeah so
[ __ ] wrong like Kurt cuz you can see
his hip city cuz I could watch his hips
in that uniform you like the yellow and
black yellow was your favorite song
Steve show listens great song rap pecan
greatest [ __ ] start
deny that but I you ask me in my opinion
who was the best captain
let's put corn are you guys speaking
English because of Wrath of Khan you're
wrong but I will say first contact is a
great film okay you probably know you
probably think Chris Pine is the best
one I don't I feel like you do I'm not
into it you not at all did thing you man
and I met and I met Chris Pine oh I
wasn't mad at that he's just not the
best just a name drop a little bit there
I met him real quick
he called you a Boomer well first of all
I didn't hear that part yeah he did
yes dog [ __ ] up both of you do right now
I'm hoppin you up bro no no you try to
start [ __ ] ya don't start [ __ ] what the
point to here what's the best Star Wars
movie to me the conversational be the
pirate has a suck as a teenager happen
to that much responsibility and not
being able to like we recently saw the
first episode like what do you imagine
your teenager you know it's kind of
vulnerable time you find out you got
these cool powers but then you look in
the mirror and see yourself in the suit
now no recent boners shoot teenager for
some reason you look like you're 25
actually have sex for the first time
[ __ ] Rito baby like actually is alpha
alphas like an elf is like if not for
this communicator you wouldn't even have
a chance with her think about that no
worries there that Billie Kent wasn't
getting land he's pretty good-looking I
know why do we make him feel like so
dorky
it's his persona that was a character it
was a lot of hidden racism a stereotyped
scenario was the Yellow Ranger the blue
collar kid is the blue Rayna I got a
right to [ __ ] to here
was the budget for Angel Grove with
every bill to see these are the weekly
population was 300 people with AIDS are
growing the name of the power range are
you absolutely arrangers real man real
name wasn't really my god David Yost
Jones jr. was one but not a lot of
people didn't know he could break dance
and he had nine fingers I did not know
that yeah I know I found that when I
went to Fox Kids Club in st. Louis I was
like twelve years old when I first met
him and now he's a good friend
Walter's busy videos what did he or did
he not break dance in the intro to that
show yeah absolutely there did a Bible
oh good yeah he did like a [ __ ] slow
real quick
Trini died you don't see that in classic
was it was it was an auto accident I do
not know the actress's name who paid
training yeah all right well this is a
buzzkill witnessing our first episode of
geek wars know that risk new show DQ
nerd wars no no you said geek words will
go with that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]